There's no denying the first Star Wars spinoff
film is a major hit.
But looking back at the early trailers for
Rogue One, it's obvious the story changed
a lot during its reportedly extensive reshoots.
So what's different?
Here's a look at some misleading trailer moments
that didn't add up in Rogue One.
Jyn's perp walk
In the first trailer, Jyn is led into the
Rebel base in handcuffs, and then has a tense
back and forth with Mon Mothma:
"On your own from the age of 15.
Reckless, aggressive, and undisciplined."
"This is a rebellion isn't it?
I rebel."
Afterwards, Mon Mothma gives Jyn her marching
orders:
"We have a mission for you.
A major weapons test is imminent, and we need
to know what it is and how to destroy it."
Along with this brief pep talk:
"Our Rebellion is all that remains to push
back the Empire."
Just one thing, though… none of this is
actually in the final film, with the exposition
about Jyn's history coming during her confrontation
with Saw Gerrera instead.
Speaking of which...
What happened to Saw?
Remember that foreboding voiceover from Saw
in the trailer?
"What will you do when they catch you?
What will you do if they break you?
If you continue to fight, what will you become?"
Exciting.
Exhilarating.
Completely missing from the movie, along with
a bit where Jyn seems to be trying to convince
Forest Whitaker's character to fight the good
fight — instead of the other way around:
"This is our chance to make a real difference."
Oh, and there's the fact that Saw used to
be bald and not quite so mangled in the previews.
We're not sure what the filmmakers originally
intended for Saw, but it seems to have been
quite different from what they ended up with.
Welcome to Jedha
One of the coolest shots from the first trailers
was this clip of a broken down Jedi statue
on the moon of Jedha.
But while we do see the statue in the film,
it's not this shot.
It's not the only thing about Jedha missing
from the finished film: this brief clip of
captured X-Wing pilots being marched to their
doom by stormtroopers is gone too.
The entire ending is different
One thing we can glean from the trailers is
that they rewrote the entire ending of the
movie.
This awesome bit where Jyn faces off against
a TIE fighter?
That's gone, as is this iconic shot of Jyn
standing in a hallway looking badass.
And left on the cutting room floor is this
bit where Krennic gets his cape dirty down
on the bloody beaches of Scarif.
But the biggest clue as to why all those shots
are missing?
Well, this clip of Jyn running along the beach
carrying the plans to the Death Star points
to a major rewrite, since in the final film
she transmits them from the tower and doesn't
fight on the beach at all.
We're not sure why they changed the ending,
but it's clear the reshoots altered almost
everything.
More Darth Vader
Finally, the early trailers offered up our
first peeks at Darth Vader's cinematic return,
but it's obvious there were at least one or
two additional Vader scenes that were filmed,
including a different exchange with Krennic.
It begs the question: Why not include as much
Vader as possible?
Everyone knows that Darth Vader makes everything
better.
"Check this out...here's...I've seen better
first pitches but, ya know."
"Nice block by Mr. Red though."
"Ya he did block it, good technique."
That, and pizza.
Now I want pizza.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!